who EJ my number one husband North Korea
Kim Jong ah not at all - ha ha
good tip oh you can get it somewhere Hey
ooh
Stinkum litigious is he keep any tongs
on a hair or should I do Michael
hmm oh you got somebody got ya but walk
with me ah take a [ __ ] yeah yeah she
buddy
she paid me a shake it pop up go Jessica
that's Kim Jung eat a robber he's a
Wyatt of course you're not that one but
immensely beautiful power to die
Chung nanny but you can even own a Tiago
honey could could the kannada yeah I
don't I call you Mook well chickie
commutator is ya ha now you got somebody
I got door ones yeah
and Anika hmm come on baby
I stuck it uh katana be nice and good
you know everybody sink Osama died Osama
what I hear the mr. Penn High prom white
never go seek continuing coverage North
Korean leader Kim Jong Il's
is dead Oh your club
look jealous dream hunter hyung EDA is a
number one husband but also number one
English speaker in all about the most
Acharya yeah ha ha this each apart back
yeah legitimate under my hey is she my
mom my English department perfected will
the perfect yeah it's perfect
hey you're too rocky bowtie hey Tony on
this I don't know what I don't know she
wants sunglasses impose on the Messiah
yes to the sex like Kim Jong era is like
a gorila oh no no Tiger Tiger
yeah I don't you yeah she can you do I
tell you to be okay Casey character
who's gay character don't hasta manana
oh okay she can not turn shall teach
each other has to be I'm over teacher
gap for joy kissing yeah so talk
tonight is the all you not that one oh
good man okay Holly watch it yeah
look but if not no pours a choco cheater
yeah
no honest laughing as I finish to be
honest I am NOT the hippie I cannot see
I have no appetite
I can't eat I wear the pants when do
they go to the soul
Claire ogress popped in the thymus or to
say Oh mmm good aerobic hotties nothing
out Chrissa nothing water get clean
water yo yo uh hello we're working on
black for me huh
you